[Music]
they just announced the lockdown
we're getting through it i hate your
face my face i hate your face
oh you hate my face it's just your face
i hate it
we should never got together in the
first place madness you know is this is
it a lockdown phenomenon or other people
experiencing this
there's this particular mushroom and
it's going to kill you i would love to
pick that mushroom
and watch that bastard die
i mean not really the only thing keeping
us together is our child
arthur my first fair you gave me a great
song i didn't give them to you
now i think you've got the same level of
charm as diarrhea
in a pint glass
i'm worried about mum little artie he's
only got one grandparent
hospital was weird it's just just trying
to make sure that people don't
die alone both my parents are dead so
you know thank god
that's really grim and i was thinking
that as i was saying it's a bit grim
we need to get on i hate you sometimes
but i never
despise you i don't want to go back to
normal
running towards each other at the speed
of light shout and get away from me
i just i can't do that anymore
we did it in the kitchen this morning
over the dishwasher i mean that is
unfathomable
[Music]
i think there's this chance that we
somehow ended up in this place that is
the
love that exists beyond hate it's unique
did you hear that in a song or something
[Music]
what we're doing doesn't mean nothing to
me
well i feel for you it's so weird are
you trying to say you love me
i'm trying to say i sort of love you
i cried in the back yesterday
the bath
you